[Music]
the first-ever MTV movie and TV Awards
have wrapped et was inside for the
star-studded event and here are four
things you didn't see on TV I see
sunrise
Emma Watson delivered an emotional
speech after taking home the first-ever
gender-neutral acting honor what you
missed was Adam Devine golf clamping on
tables for Bell as the Beast yes yes new
couple alert Zac Efron was spotted
grabbing Baywatch co-star alexandra
daddario hand and kissing it a far cry
from when the two presented on stage
together yes you gave me get it we get
the point thank you Alex
[Music]
Big Sean had the crowd on their feet and
the rapper also apparently had rebel
Wilson dancing and drinking straight
from a champagne bottle picked a
princess I realize he was princess but
what you really missed from the comforts
of your living room the downpour and
hail
you heard it hail that shut down the red
carpet early eighties Michelle Turner
was there so this is how team
entertainment tonight does the MTV movie
and TV Awards the band is still playing
but the hail is coming down we're soaked
[Music]
you